[Musik]
zugeschaltet aus berlin ist uns thomas
bareiß cdu parlamentarischer
staatssekretär im bundesministerium für
wirtschaft und technologie und
tourismusbeauftragter der
bundesregierung weise ich grüße sie in
die hauptstadt sie stehen in ihrem
ministerium und wahrscheinlich schon in
den startlöchern
auch alles umzusetzen was möglicherweise
heute entschieden wird reisen im
pandemie zeiten gleicht ein bisschen
einem laborversuch jetzt stehen wir also
wieder vor einer neuen schwelle der
entscheidung und viele fragen sich was
geht jetzt aktuell wenn im grunde
genommen in dieser beschlussvorlage
steht möglichst gar nicht reisen die vor
allem guten morgen ich glaube das wird
ein ganz ganz wichtigen tag haben und
dass wir auch ein thema reisen wieder
vorsichtiger sein wissen ich glaube die
lage ist ernst das wird der heutige tag
verbringen das für die nächsten wochen
einfach noch vorsichtig sein müssen dort
wo fallen die ansteckungsraten sehr hoch
sind
ich habe nach wie vor auch die große
hoffen dass wir dort wo der staat
niedrig sind wo wir regional auch
wirklich auch bessere werte haben dass
wir auch da weiterhin offen bleiben
können dass wir auch der reisenden
ermöglichen können dass die kontaktlosen
reisen.de sowie ferienwohnungen oder
auch bei ferienhäusern
wir kämpfen plätzen auch etwas offener
sein können und ich hoffe auch dass
dieses empfinden und durch das testen
auch mehr reisen zukünftige wirklichen
über sicherheit schaffen können auch
dazu braucht es klare botschaften
das sind ja zwei komplizierte dinge das
testen und das impfen in deutschland
konzentrieren wir beide uns noch ein
bisschen stärker auf das reisen was
natürlich unterfüttert werden muss durch
gute hygiene konzepte es gibt sie haben
das mehr oder weniger angesprochen von
den nordländern diese idee also
mecklenburg-vorpommern niedersachsen
schleswig-holstein reisen im eigenen
bundesland das heißt sie unterstützen
das ich glaube die menschen haben vor
ort die landminen virus umzugehen wir
haben jetzt zwölf monate viel gelernt
wir haben viel auch angeschafft ein
sicherheitsmaßnahmen gerade die hotels
die restaurants haben enorm viel
investiert also ich glaube dass dort
auch enorm viel sicherheit geschaffen
worden ist dass verantwortung da ist
insofern bin ich auch überzeugt dass
dort wo die intense werde niedrig sind
durchaus auch
reisen wirklich ist sowieso dort wurde
ich dann bei ferienhäusern
ferienwohnungen kontaktloses reisen auch
die faktor möglichst das ist ja ähnlich
wie zu hause
insofern bin ich davon überzeugt dass
auch gerade diese regionen wo viele
ferienhäuser und ferienwohnungen sind
auch wirklich wieder mehr urlauber
empfangen werden können ich glaube das
gilt auch zu dass wir die maßnahme die
der zeit durchführen auch
verhältnismäßig machen und auch
nachvollziehbar
die menschen machen nur dann gut wenn
sie auch denken dass die die maßnahmen
die wir vornehmen nicht nur hat sensoren
dass sie auch wirklich verhältnismäßig
sind und ich glaube ferienwohnungen ist
es schwer begründbar warum hier nicht
nicht den vielen hohen und versuchen
sollten trotzdem gibt es auch da
außenkontakte ich gebe das einkaufen etc
wie sähe denn dann ein sozusagen stammt
- jene konzept wie sähe denn einstellen
will ihre konzept dann da einfach aus
heißt das ich werde getestet oder ich
weiß bei einreise dann ihnen das urlaubs
bundesland einen entsprechenden
negativen selbsttest vor als ich darf
das test nicht generell ganz ganz
wichtige strategie auf den nächsten
wochen monate wir haben uns die test
kapazitäten stark nach oben gefahren das
testen muss gerade auch für den alltag
mit ganz ganz große rolle spielen
wir brauchen täglich der jede woche ein
zweites dass der dass die personen
sicher sind wenn sie rausgehen können
auch glaube ich viel viel mehr dinge tun
wenn wir einen negativen test vorlegen
können und es gab ja viele
urlaubsregionen die ganz konkret gesagt
haben jetzt wenn wir es schaffen dann
beim einkommen ein negativ test
vorzulegen weil wir brauchen den
deutschen ins länder nordsee oder ostsee
und weggehen wieder negativ test hat
dann kann man ja für beide seiten an
sicherheit schaffen und ist das was wir
stärker nutzen müssen um wie gesagt mehr
freizügigkeit auch wieder einzubauen und
wieder auch mehr reisen zu könig das
wollen die menschen und ich haben die
menschen auch nach zwölf monaten auch
wieder bitter nötig und die weil die
urlaubsregionen die haben jetzt wie
gesagt sehr viel investiert und auch
sehr viele eingebracht und ich glaube
die sind bitter freuen sich dringend
denn sie wieder freuen sich sehr wenn
sie wieder gäste empfangen dürfen
eine sache ist ein bisschen auf
unverständnis gestoßen das auswärtige
amt die bundesregierung hat die
reisewarnung zum beispiel nach mallorca
aufgehoben aber auch verschiedene andere
destinationen zwei drittel der
bundesbürger konnten das in umfragen
nicht so gut verstehen konnten vor allen
dingen nicht verstehen wie man nach
mallorca reisen wieder zurückkehren und
das ohne quarantäne und ohne
vielleicht verstehen sie das also auch
für mich war das bitter dass wir
mallorca möglich machen können das ist
doch keine reisewarnung ergibt aber das
schwarzwaldhotel oder aufzustellen
nordsee ostsee er muss weiterhin
geschlossen bleiben ich denke das ist
etwas was uns sehr auch wirklich weh tut
er aber mallorca hat derzeit sehr
niedrige werte werde teilweise die unter
30 inzidenz werte sind das heißt
eigentlich reisen dort noch sicher und
wir können natürlich die auch die
reisewarnungen immer auf aufwerten
aufbauen die auch realistisch sind die
auch entsprechend nachvollziehbar sind
und die auch verlässlich so von da kann
man ja auch man kann nicht auf dauer
geschlossen hat gesagt wir sind auch da
regional vorgehen wie deutschland auch
und deshalb ist man ja wie gesagt mit
einer reisewarnung gelegt an regionen
europa sind es noch und ich hoffe dass
wir auch in deutschland dieses regionale
betrachtung starke wieder auch
anzunehmen und das will auch david
regionen auch öffnen können wenn die
technik sind um auch wirklich auch bei
uns in deutschland urlaub zu machen auch
dieses ganz ganz wichtig für die 2,5
millionen beschäftigte branche richtig
da geht es vom viele jobs von
arbeitsplätze und existenzen da
sozusagen politik im moment herbei auf
sicht fährt traue ich mir jetzt auch
nicht mit ihnen über das projekt
sommerurlaub zu sprechen das vertagen
für ein nächstes gespräch aber ich
möchte eine letzte frage stellen als
mitglied des bundesvorstandes der cdu
nach der masken affäre gibt sich ihre
schwester partei die csu jetzt ganz
aktuell einen verhaltenskodex da geht es
sozusagen um compliance da geht es um
integrität der cdu-sozialflügel hat
heute morgen jetzt erklärt die cdu wir
brauchen das auch wie sehen sie das
braucht dass die cdu als ein kleiner
einschub noch mal wenn ich dann mal auf
ist durchaus wichtig und ich glaube dass
wir wirklich perspektive haben
es sind eher in feier fern wie wir haben
auch den impfstoff der schnell jetzt
auch da ist wir werden die nächsten
wochen auch über den hausarzt werden
würde impfstoff auch abweichen das heißt
ich getrost als wir im sommer wirklich
hohe sicherheit haben und dass viele
menschen auch geimpft sind und dann auch
wieder reisen für viele möglichst nach
wirklich die branche wieder mit
volldampf fahren können und zum anderen
thema glaube ich dass wir in deutschland
sehr hohe transparenz werte haben wir in
deutschland eine enorm hohe anforderung
auch an die abgeordneten ihre einkünfte
entsprechend auch nebentätigkeit nach
aufzulegen
ich halte es auch ganz gerne
die für transparenz zu sorgen und
ehrlichkeit und offenheit
ich habe das immer getan von mir auch
sehr klar und deutlich gesagt was ich
gemacht habe und und auch wo ich
entsprechende auch termine hatte es war
habe ich immer klar dass die menschen
auch die mich gewählt haben wissen
wissen wo ich bin insofern denke ich mal
dass auch das noch mal die nächsten
monate große rolle spielen soll und dort
wollen verbesserungen machen kann immer
noch weitere auch möglichkeit schafft an
der transparenz bin ich gern bereit
damit zu machen ich glaube das ist kein
jetzigen zeit schwierig ist hier
wirklich glaubhaft oder glaubwürdigkeit
auch zugeben
deshalb denke ich mir das auch dann noch
mal ein starkes angebot gegeben werden
muss dass wir transparenz ernst nehmen
und wirklich auch da nicht zu sagen
haben und dass viele menschen in der
politik sind die wirklich glaubwürdig
und sehr engagiert für die menschen
arbeiten und das beste rausholen wollen
das ist unser antrieb und das muss auch
fremd herum school
vielen dank für diese klare position
auch jetzt noch zum ende der
parlamentarische staatssekretär der cdu
im bundeswirtschaftsministerium thomas
bareiß heute morgen im phoenix
tagesgespräch dankeschön nach berlin